une victoire où les doutes les jaune et
noir de plaisir devait impérativement
battre thionville à domicile ce samedi
25 janvier pour s'éloigner de la zone de
relégation
ce match de nationale 3 commence
pourtant mal pour les locaux les
visiteurs mènent rapidement 9 à 6 face à
des plaisirs wa sans solution là j'avoue
que je n'ai pas trop d'explications sur
les quatre cinq premières minutes
ok
on a l'impression que la température
qu'il fait ici il était gelé et que les
lorrains ont un peu plus habitués donc
et l'on pose problème mais pas
d'explication au que psychologique où je
sais pas franchement on est resté dans
les starting blocks après un sursaut de
plaisir les deux équipes repartent
finalement aux vestiaires sur le score
de 14 partout on rend très mal dans le
match on pense qu'on défend pas on
défend pas correctement mais pas assez
de profondeur on va pas les chercher à
théo et derrière dès qu'on a récupéré le
ballon n'a pu les monte donc c'est pour
ça qu'on obtient un match nul en
première mi temps
en deuxième période plaisir accélère et
se détachent les joueurs comptent
jusqu'à dix buts d'avancé après 15
minutes de jeu sur ville ne reviendra
pas au score final 30 à 24
ça fait du bien d'avoir d'avoir les
trois points parce que c'était
l'objectif
en gagnant ce match on leur passe devant
au classement et ça niveau comptable ça
fait vraiment du bien donc final la
manière passer en second plan et on voit
qu'on fait une excellente deuxième
mi-temps pour la finalité c'est c'est
bien pour le couple au classement
plaisir est aujourd'hui 8,6 avec un
point de plus que son adversaire du jour
et s'éloigne de la zone de relégation
prochain match pour confirmer ce samedi
1er février contre villemomble toujours
admissible